five and a half back of the sixth spot
so they're destined if they can hang on
for
one of the spots in the playing below
all the way scoop it up and in walking
back the Angelo they're looking for
their fifth streak of at least three
games
just got lost completely defensive their
defense is getting Tighter and Tighter
is their confidence on the offensive
side gets higher and higher
rebound collected by D'Angelo Russell
defense gets back Delo goes around one
and one what a move by D'Angelo Russell
Reeves trying to negotiate his way to
some space
and a shoulder fake by Russell back out
to rui for three
112 103 over Memphis he's playing
short-handed of course no John that game
now the right side wide open Intruder
got it good luck that time by gilo yeah
from Beyond New York
by Davis good play by A.D now he's
running the floor D'Angelo Russell now
finds A.D there he is
Anthony Davis had inside position starts
with your defense but then you have to
reward your big blockcher gets the
rebound get him an opportunity the
Lakers up too
of course the big key was struck baby
coming back
so backhandling and left is good because
he's made a couple of real nice plays
with one ball fake just think a little
bit of backhand left over a much taller
he's got 15 game leading scorers
[Applause]
10.
and hatchimal with the easy Lefty
just blocked one a moment ago Russell
again
oh thanks little magic for kilo matches
their biggest lead they Trail by as many
as 15. Russell going into again
D'Angelo Russell
[Music]
[Applause]
what was he doing Boy George was
telegraphing
[Applause]
transitional three giving the Lakers a
four-point lead
travel take it by the Lakers Delo with
the Lakers up by six stop shoot score
time out Toronto Schroeder
D'Angelo little two-man
pulls up drifting right shooting left of
course that's a little bit easier for a
lefty exactly right they're thinking
about getting at least into the top six
they do not have the illusions of
grandeur oh D'Angelo
D'Angelo deep look out of the timeout
look at this look where the defender is
and look where he shoots this from that
is a quick hit and long-range bomb there
he's now four out of seven from behind
The Arc in route to 25 points well with
LeBron out and delo Outreach Intruder
were just piling up the minute gilo
again
again for Russell another look at the
last the Angelo three catch let fire
fight